when did you start playing the drums um
a couple
my dad was a professional tennis player
so i grew up in in the world of tennis
and traveled around the tennis circle
all over the world were you almost a
professional tennis player uh i was in
my mind i was almost a professional
tennis is that what you wanted to do to
bond with your father um i don't know if
it was to bond with my father but i
wanted to uh it was what i knew so it
was sort of what i wanted to do and in
denmark i was actually in the 12th and
14th i was ranked in the top 10 in the
country in denmark in denmark okay which
is about you know the size of the west
village
but nevertheless
a pretty big accomplishment yeah it but
it was also you know you understand i
come from a
sort of a tennis dynasty family my
father was the best tennis player in
denmark his brother was the second best
tennis player in denmark and so your
your entire childhood was devoted to
more toward tennis than learning the
drums tennis was tennis was kind of my
day job music was my passion and it was
the same thing with my father my father
loved music there was a lot of music
around the household when i was growing
up he
actually in his spare time from playing
tennis wrote about music for danny's
newspapers did your father ever say to
you listen if you want to be a great
tennis player knock off the music
passion and get passionate about tennis
no pressure that way no
but what happened was that when i
finished uh the school in denmark when i
was 16 i came to america to play tennis
for a year at you know nick boleter oh
sure in florida that's the big tennis
scene yeah yeah so the first year that
uh nick bulletiere's tennis academy in
sarasota florida got off the ground i
was there and i was the only kid out of
the 50 kids that was there that didn't
go to school because i'd finished school
in denmark so i was there in the tennis
academy did nick terry say to you hey
kid you've got some talent here and i
think you can go places or did he just
basically say listen you're wasting your
time go be a drummer from a town
what did he say uh nick said jump on it
that was the main thing he said to me
for yourself jump on it kid jump on it
jump on the ball jump on the ball so i
would do my best to jump whenever nick
nick spent a lot i don't want to be
disrespectful here but nick spent a lot
of time there was kind of a pecking
order system so over on court one was
where all the you know jimmy areas all
the star kids were and
i i was
lucky in the fact that obviously he was
very respectful of my father so i was up
on maybe court two or three but isn't
that a good learning technique in other
words he makes it so you want to be on
court once it's humiliating in a way
and he would sort of wander over to the
lower courts occasionally and then you
know he would come over come on over
jump on it jump on it okay
wow this is what we paid 20 000
did that discourage you from becoming a
professional tennis player um
yes could you have made a pro career out
of tennis do you think no what happened
was that i didn't actually make uh make
it on the tennis team at the high school
in newport beach
i wasn't one of the seven best tennis
players in your high school in corolla
del mar high school and that was a bit
of a buzzkill
what was the problem that you couldn't
become a great professional tennis um i
didn't have the tenacity to do the six
eight hours of of all that [ __ ] every
day i was just tennis you know why i
grew up tennis was something that was
about having fun was a social element
you know all the players down at the
clubs they would play and then they
would afterwards they would drink beers
and smoke cigarettes it was kind of like
a very social endeavor so in a sense you
believe your philosophy is that you had
the natural talent it's just that you
didn't have this insane drive that
middle-class parents put into that they
all want the next macan route and i also
got i got kind of turned off by the um
but that thing of six hours every day
just drills down the line and and it's
no longer fun
it it just became very uh uh
i don't know military it was just it was
about it was very hard-edged and growing
up in denmark where everything's kind of
like a guy you float along and very
important and you just play games i
can't even picture you in the outfit
quite frankly there's this sweater
i had the silly little shorts on like
everybody else in 1979 that were way too
small at the time i see wearing black
with maybe a devil thing or something i
remember those little shorts that were
like that big man with a little little
shorts hard to get laid it's a lot
easier to get laid in metallica than it
is to being in tennis and when you see
those pictures now you're thinking what
the [ __ ] how do we get into those